he's the number one overall pick the
pride of Washington and now the
Philadelphia 76ers Markel folds where
are you today
Markel on my way to Philly right now
hain't feeling I'll be brief and I'm
blessed and honored so I'm really happy
right now just what what can I can't
wait to get it ready so how'd you
celebrate last night I would sleep what
time you go to bed
what'd you say what times you go to bed
uh no I didn't get back to Lee so I
product there right through for how many
interviews you think you did last night
my art Thank You Lee 50 Wow so you're
tired of talking about yourself not
really I mean it's a great opportunity
and uh I mean I like it so I really
bought hair as much what were you doing
a year ago at this time if I was
probably in the gym somewhere working
out or shooting trick shots or playing
did you go to prom last year yes are
there a lot yeah last year I did go to
problem will you promise yeah I don't
think we had frolicking Oh
or you would have wanted yeah for sure
of course you would have would you do
with gear up your basketball shoes that
you had on last night yeah I put them
back in the box and sign them and they
keep bound and they're gonna be like a
couple of rupees I like that when you
worked out what was different about
Philadelphia when you worked out for
Boston
you worked out for the Lakers in
Philadelphia give me the difference in
working on for those teams first of all
go for three teams and I enjoy both very
energetic and uh I think they know
different was that if the players came
up to show love it and all the Philly
and all we got up and down full-court so
pretty much it
well I love it the the 76er players came
out to your workout
I thought that was a great really
appreciated yeah not I was cooler to
show that how they feel it just made it
a little bit easier on me maybe should
like out at home so how are you going to
be listed are you a point guard or a
shooting guard um alright whatever you
need me to win if that's the Garter or
should be yourself
but do you want to be a point guard it
feels like you know that we talked about
the point guards the designation of a
point guard that when we talk about the
great you know ball handlers it's the
point guards yeah that's the definitely
wanna be extra did you have posters of
players on your wall growing up not
really I mean yeah I sure did I'd like
Shaq Kobe key a lot of people who do you
want to be facing though now you get
this opportunity who do you look forward
to everybody and how long important
thing is everybody no one person actors
play again help I'm looking forward to
coming up how goofy is Jill Ellen bead
God he's character everybody shoot that
I mean be so fun but at the same time he
has a respectful manner he carries
himself the right way what criticisms
bothered you the most through this
process because when they analyzed draft
pick say they'll give you the good but
then they're going to you know nitpick
and give you the bad they're just trying
to say I'm not a winner
that's all I really think that they're
really didn't physical I'll know where
anybody knows me in and play with me did
not give a competitor and everything
like that I am so well how did you
explain then the nine wins when people
ask or did you have to explain that how
could you win nine games and you're the
best player in the country yeah I mean I
mean disguiser just goes to my resume
and I saw teammates how I came to
practice every day and how hard I worked
every day and how motivated there's a
kind of practices and if you looked at
before college I'm a USA basketball my
high school at the BAFTA I mean common
power than they will win it is pretty
strong so I got a game plan for you
today Travis
you stop by go to go to a cheesesteak
stand and whoever is there whatever
crowd is there you buy cheese steaks for
everybody and you know they'll be like
maybe eight ten twelve people but then
they're going to tell everybody Markel
folds just stop by bought cheese steaks
for everybody
cooker that's it alright it's very
subtle sneaky and I'll give that
gameplan to you on the house the next
one I'll probably have to charge you
okay hey safe travels congrats big
moment for you and enjoy the 76ers thank
you that's marquel volts seventy Sixers
guard I don't know if he's a point guard
or not he's whatever you want him to be
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience